notre destination du jour se situe au
nord d'orléans au coeur d'une petite
commune rurale neuville aux bois
bonjour bonjour on est chez vous ici
alors vous étiez en appartement avant
c'est pas la démarche la plus commune
que de passer d'un appartement à une
maison effectivement vu arriver à 60 ans
et faire l'inversé mais on avait fait le
choix d'un appartement
le temps où les enfants étaient
scolarisés ils pouvaient partir vaquer
c'est un choix choix de vie après les
enfants et les petits-enfants donc
l'envi de volume des espaces une
possibilité de voir plus grand de voir
autrement voilà
voir plus grand et différents en milieu
urbain c'est un choix qui dépend aussi
de l'administration
on est dans le périmètre des bâtiments
de france il fallait effectivement on
est près de l'église
les frais de l'église l'église qui est
classée donc on est dans un périmètre de
500 mètres de l'église et il fallait
l'aval des bâtiments de france pour le
projet alors pour avoir cet aval
qu'est-ce que vous avez dû faire comme
compromis on va dire n'a pas eu à vrai
dire ça pas été de gros compromis dcc de
la négociation c'est de la présentation
c'est de la conservation et puis on y
arrive
la maison c'est une ossature bois pour
ça évite le bardage et en bois il aurait
pu être un partage traditionnel de ça se
fait aussi mes deux fils on avait choisi
un bardage bien parce que le boire
vieillissant et le contexte urbain
paraissait mieux mieux adaptés
satisfaisait pleinement l'architecte des
bâtiments de france tant mieux quand on
colorie
s'est mis d'accord avec lui lui sans
problème la maison a été monté en trois
semaines sur un terrain familial par le
cabinet d'architectes le de raincourt
gens installés en eure et loir est
spécialisé dans les maisons en bois
l'ossature des murs et enfin avec une
isolation en feutre de bois le bardage à
l'extérieur et enfin français
et cette maison donc vous l'aviez
dessinée ou l'aviez imaginé vous l'avez
vous avez même fait une petite maquette
on peut aller voir et bien sûr il est
temps de faire un tour à l'intérieur
l'occasion pour jean louis de ressortir
quelques souvenirs de la maison ça oui
je m'inquiète de ce projet de maison qui
effectivement servir à convaincre si
besoin était les bâtiments de france qui
ont pu effectivement visualiser les
volumes tout de suite repéré hauteur
si la maison n'est pas tout-à-fait bbc
elle est classée à pour ses performances
énergétiques
les murs en bois avec le barde achète
une bonne isolation pour la maison oui
le saturn bois plus une isolation en
feutre de bois c'est une bonne c'est un
bon facteur d'isolant temps sur l'hiver
que sur l'été sur la pénétration de la
chaleur aussi effectivement c'est
quelque chose de positif
vous le sentez ça par rapport à vos
anciens lieux de vie où vous habitiez
avant il ya une vraie différence de
confort ailleurs oui oui c'est certain
une différence de confort de parler
d'eux par l'exposition la pénétration du
soleil de la lumière
et puis chauffage le plancher chauffant
c'est quelque chose de très agréable
très doux comme chauffage c'est très
confortable et puis effectivement le
type de construction fait que
économiquement parlant j'ai pas plus
cher de charges en appartement et les
économies d'énergie ne se situe pas
forcément là où on les attend
ces petites plantes c'est ce que vous
avez sur une partie de votre toit c'est
ça ces cassettes végétalisée et sont sur
le toit terrasse au-dessus de la chambre
sur le youtube ont décalé et c'est une
isolation supplémentaire intéressante et
spécialement l'été où il ya une
pénétration de la chaleur nettement
moins importante alors c'est des petites
plantes grasses et ça c'est du cdh homme
se doit s'appeler comme ça c'est vrai
bon c'est rigolo il y en avait 2 ans
ravages des effets posé là j'y touche
pas et vivent naturellement comme ça
j'ai pas grimper l'eau pour voir ce qui
se passe ces deux baromètres mon témoin
m
qu'est ce que ça vous a apporté de
travailler sur ce projet de maison pas
du plaisir parce qu'on l'a fait avec
beaucoup de plaisir
et puis maintenant on est content du
résultat effectivement on est satisfait
de se retrouver ici est à moitié dehors
et quand même dedans donc ces deux côtés
sympathiques de la chose avec les
écureuils qui se promènent et les
petites maisons ce qui donne de voir ses
biens
à une époque de la vie où l'on a
tendance à rétrécir son espace jean
louis sa femme danielle se sont offert
de nouveaux horizons